today everybody takes politics so damn
seriously they think it's the be-all the
end-all of the whole world political
battles matter but C.S Lewis pointed
this out he said a sick Society needs to
talk about politics if you don't talk
about politics the sickness could get
worse but if all you're talking about is
politics then you've lost the point of
the society in the first place the
reason we have politics is so that we
can engage in culture so that we can
worship God as we want to worship God so
that we can have relationships with our
family and our communities and our civil
society and that those free associations
that make America what it is a society
that can't laugh a little bit at its
politics they can't take itself lightly
it doesn't have that you know the writer
G.K Chesterton said the angels can fly
because they can take themselves lightly
it's not that they take themselves
unseriously it's not that they make a
joke of themselves but they can take
themselves lightly and if we can't do
that in politics the future doesn't look
so bright